what is going on everybody welcome to
part 15 of our intermediate Python
series we've been talking about
object-oriented programming and that's
what we're going to continue talking
about here first what we're going to do
is we're going to show how we can using
our pretty simple class create a bunch
of blue blobs and even a bunch of a few
red blobs will create a handful of each
and we'll show how that kind of works
and then we're also going to just show
really quickly like a way to give them
IDs and stuff like that and then after
that we're gonna get into talking about
modularity and just one of the problems
I already have with this class that we
wrote but I wanted to keep it this way
at first because this is so caught this
is like more of like a fun way to write
this as a function as opposed to how
object-oriented programming really ought
to be so I just wanted to first do it
one way and illustrate to you exactly
why doesn't work but anyways let's get
into it so the first thing I want us to
do is add a couple new constants and the
constants will be starting blue blobs
and we'll say that's ten and then we're
gonna add starting red blobs and that's
gonna be three now what I want to do is
come down to the main and rather than
just one red blob we're going to create
a bunch of blobs so let's just say that
we wanted to create a bunch of blue
blobs how would we how do I it might we
do that well we might say not all caps
anymore
blue blobs my teeth will something like
blob blue for I in range starting blue
blobs okay so we might do that and that
would just be a list of blue blob or a
list of blob objects that happen to have
the color attribute as being blue or the
tuple for blue so that's fine that would
work we could pass that to draw
environment and then for each of the
blobs we could do this it would just
literally be for blob and blue blob you
know you would just base it right here
for
or blob in blue blobs which we would
pass here as not there might be the
blobs parameter let's say and then we
pass it down here as blue blobs for blob
in blue blobs we might do this and
there's a boom okay we've probably got
many blobs in fact let's run it and just
see what happens no I just wanted to
make sure blue for blob in blue blobs
what I messed up was here so should be
for blob and blobs and then oh we're
printing the red blob at the end here
let's get rid of that otherwise it'll
work Oh only one is moving oh because
blob dot move sorry this was meant to
just be really quick example but it's
not going so quick but we can move this
blob here save and now they will all
move yes syntax said all right so that's
really quickly but what we really
probably ought to do is somehow give
these blobs an ID if only we had a way
to just give them an ID oh yeah so one
option we have is we could we could we
could do something like this we could
say dict like this but we still need
some sort of ID elements so we could say
dict enumerate and now what we should
have is the index and then the act and
the index will be the dictionary key and
the value will actually be that blue
blob so now they actually have an ID so
then when we pass blobs into here it
would be four blob in blobs so really
what it should be is lob ID in blobs
will then say blob equals blobs and then
that blob ID
and there we have now all the blobs are
moving around but we also have
individual IDs for those blobs so we
could let's just print blue blobs here
right so as we can see it's a dictionary
and now each of the blobs has a unique
ID and the object is being stored in
that dictionary and just real quick well
I mean why might we really want like why
do we need an ID like well for example
we're gonna create red blobs here in a
moment and red blobs need or we're gonna
just say that when a blue blob collides
with a red blob that's a bad thing and
maybe the red blob kills the blue blob
we need to know which blue blob is that
so if it's just a without dict and
enumerate if it's just this if it's just
a list of blob objects we don't know
which objects that really it like we
have no way of like being like okay that
okay we know that object now let's
delete that out we it's really difficult
to do that there's one thing we might do
is we could have like some sort of
attribute in the blob that says like is
alive or something like that so I mean
there are things that we could do to
kind of handle for this but I think it's
probably a wise idea to give it the
blobs some sort of ID now we know the
blobs ID if something happens to that
blob where you can save that sum
somewhere so we give that blob an ID
another option could be to assign up an
ID in the init method as this blob is
born but the chances depend on how many
blobs you're gonna create it so on like
you might have blobs with conflicting
IDs and then you got to think about
doing like random IDs and it just it's
probably best not to have that in the in
the blob itself but you could it doesn't
matter but regardless they really need
to have an ID so this is how we're gonna
do it so then we're gonna do the same
thing for red blobs we're gonna just red
blobs rather than blue it'll be red and
then starting
red blobs boom okay so now we got blue
blobs and red blobs hmm
well what we could do is just pass a
list so we could pass blue blobs red
blobs like this and then we'll say
rather than blobs will say that's blob
list and then we'll say four blobs yes
that's right
and well is it sir and then for blob in
the blobs we might also say for blob
dict and blob list maybe that would be a
little more clear what we're doing so
for blob dict
and blob lists for blob idea in blob
dict blob equals blob dict blob ID cool
let's hope that works great so there we
have one two three red blobs and the
rest are blue blobs obviously when they
collide into each other right now
nothing is actually going to happen but
there we have both blobs on their they
have IDs we could actually handle stuff
with them so now what I'd like us to do
I think I'll actually cut it here and in
the next tutorial we will discuss fixing
this class and how to kind of change our
mindset as far as how we're going to
build classes so I think this one's
already getting to be long enough so
anyways if you have questions comments
concerns whatever up to this point on
this one if you're not getting your
blobs for whatever reason if you think
there's a better way to handle this one
for example this quite a long line let
us know below otherwise I will see you
in the next tutorial